[Musique]
bonsoir josiane merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france son organisme de
santé la troisième dose et efficace à
86% contre les infections chez les plus
de 60 ans cela montre que qu'une
troisième dose sera obligatoire pour
pour l'ensemble de la population pour
lutter contre les variants en gros il va
falloir se faire vacciner tous les six
mois
j'aimerais pouvoir répondre vous réponds
mais je ne lis pas dans les boules de
cristal et aujourd'hui ce que l'on sait
c'est que la 3e 2 est efficace à plus de
86% 80% à la fin de la première semaine
et 95 94 % après deux semaines pourquoi
avons nous proposer cette 3e 2 c'est là
c'est la question qu'il faut se poser
nous avons constaté qu'au bout de
quelques mois il y avait une diminution
de l'immunité après les deux premiers
vaccins et cette troisième
vaccin et comment de booster ça permet
de faire remonter l'immunité et de se
retrouver ainsi dans une production
maximale
qu'en est il de ce qui se passera dans
quelques mois nul ne le sait nous
espérons que ce booster permettra de
faire durer longtemps cette
sécurité nous ne sommes pas sur notre
cas pour quelques mois nous en sommes à
peu près certain après personne ne le
sait tout dépendra de la forme de ce
pourquoi je vous écris ton parce
qu'évidemment vous le savez il ya de
nombreuses personnes réfractaires encore
et toujours au vaccin qu'est ce qu'on
peut leur dire parce que depuis le début
ces derniers nous disent voilà on va
nous demander de nous faire vacciner
tous tous les six mois il va ça vient
d'un très mauvais oeil qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez justement pour les
convaincre ne serait-ce que déjà de la
première dose pour certains et la
troisième dose est ce que ça ne fait pas
beaucoup
ça fait certainement beaucoup bien sûr
mais comparativement aux dégâts que
cause de l'aco vide je n'ai pas d'autres
arguments que de leur demander de faire
attention à leur vie aujourd'hui le lie
à plus de cinq millions et demi de morts
dans le monde avec un vaccin imaginez
sans vaccin ce que la sauce ce que ce
serait on a au début
certains comparent et les lacs au vide à
une sorte de grippette mais vous savez
la grippe malgré le vaccin annuel fait
300 400 mille morts ce qui est énorme
ici nous sommes à plus de cinq millions
et demi de morts il n'ya pas d'autre de
d'autres formes de 2,2 d'arguments et
puis vous savez le coc vite ce n'est pas
une simple petite maladie c'est quelque
chose qui entraîne des effets
secondaires sérieux moi j'en vois tous
les jours je voit tous les jours des
gens qui ont eu locaux vides et qui
soutient que l'ondé qui garde encore des
manifestations extrêmement pénible donc
outre outre la mort que cela entraîne ça
entraîne aussi un certain nombre de
problèmes qui sont ce qu'on appelle les
coville blanc mais également un certain
nombre d'autres problèmes de santé qui
dure qui dure et qui empoisonnent la vie
des gens c'est vraiment les seuls
arguments ces sont des arguments de
médecins que je vous donne je n'ai pas
d'autres arguments bien sûr il serait le
vacciner pardon de doses 58% de la
population pourtant
l'état hébreu et était réputé pour être
champion de la vaccination au début de
cette campagne pourquoi ça s'est ensuite
taris a ralenti pour quelles raisons
écoutez nous avons à ce jour
six millions de personnes qui ont reçu
une première deux et cinq millions et
demi de personnes qui ont reçu 2 2 et
pour compléter plus de deux millions de
personnes ont reçu la troisième 2 donc
il ya une augmentation qui se fait
lentement mais qui se fait nous avons un
problème aussi aujourd'hui avec comme
dans tous les pays du monde avec un
certain nombre de personnes qui ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner nous avons
un peu moins d'un million de personnes
qui ne ne sont pas vaccinés actuellement
un million de personnes ou un peu moins
sur neuf millions 9 mois et demi ça fait
quand même un certain pourcentage ce qui
explique qu' il y à une recrudescence
donc de 2,2 de l'aco vide avec son seau
variant delta d'où aujourd'hui les
incitations les fortes d'incitation à se
faire vacciner pour 1ère 2e 2e égalant
contre la troisième
3e 2 et vous voyez il ya un fort
engouement en israël pour cette 3e 2
puisque nous sommes aujourd'hui à plus
de 2 millions d'israéliens qui ont reçu
7 et 3 2 nous espérons ainsi que ce
rappel vaccinal portera ses fruits
d'avril sans porter ses fruits déjà
d'ailleurs et il a permis une baisse
certaine décontamination et après ce qui
a été un regain virulent mois de juin en
fait nous espérions avoir atteint une
sorte d'immunité collective en mai avril
mais mai manimal malheureusement ça n'a
pas été le cas d'où aujourd'hui cette
proposition de 3e d'autres rapidement
très rapidement docteur avec les enfants
depuis 12 ans sont concernés notamment
par cette troisième dose c'est une bonne
chose pour pour vous alors qu'ils ne
sont pas nécessairement à risque
écoutez le problème est le suivant si
vous comptez 100 personnes qui ont le
pion de le lac au vide sur 100 personnes
nous a levé 150 qui sont des enfants les
enfants heureusement ne sont pas
gravement atteints mais ils sont
extrêmement contagieux ils sont
contaminés et contaminant et donc pour
l'ensemble de la population pour pour
leurs parents leurs grands parents pour
qu'ils puissent vivre normalement la
proposition de de ce vaccin leur avait
été faite élisions intérêts 1
globalement nous avons des chiffres
importants de près de 65 à 70 % de
jeunes qui ont qui ont décidé de se
faire vacciner et il n'y a vraiment
aucune contrainte en israël c'est
vraiment une démarche volontariste et et
cela permet peut-être ne va pas
permettre comme ça de passer cet
cette vague qui arrive est de pouvoir à
peu près vivre
pas comme avant mais
merci en tout cas d'avoir été
sûr que je pense pourvu d'extérieur